it's such a beautiful day out here the
air is alive with birds on and the
gentle bubbling of nearby brooks there
are ancient oak trees everywhere
reaching up into the sky and forming a
dense canopy the occasional shaft of
light spears through amongst the leaves
illuminating the lush green moss on the
ground below as soft and perfect
underfoot as a brand new rug this might
seem like we're just having a pleasant
john through a local forest here at scp
explain but take a closer look at the
trees
this isn't just any forest dear viewers
that's right after years of attempted
espionage and infiltration
are here
at long last the wanderers library the
limitless interdimensional archive of
all knowledge in the multiverse often
frequented by the serpent's hand via
portals known as the ways who would have
guessed that the secret to getting
inside was just asking very politely and
promising not to steal any of the books
we should just try being nice more often
but hey as the dispensers of
user-friendly animated knowledge here on
youtube we felt that we ought to share
this bounty of limitless knowledge with
you the wing of the wanderers library
we're seeing right now is known as the
hidden nest it's a good starting point
for new scholars perusing the boundless
texts available beyond dimensions how
about we begin with this collection over
here king shash's shelf try saying that
three times fast and then take a look at
the inscription above the case the lord
of the lazy his kingdom is anywhere in
which sloth reigns above activity
in the hearts of all those devoted to
lounging over labor he and his secret
army wage a war against all doers a
battle for the universe that can only
end in the cessation of all motion in
the universe or total unstoppable chaos
lord of the lazy hmm
sounds like me when i clocked off for
the weekend let's crack the spines on a
few of these dusty old volumes and take
a look inside first we have on the
common vampire an extract from the
thought to be lost saint emile's
bestiary translated into english by the
famed scholar of the anomalous known as
rounderhouse it is an indispensable
source of knowledge for those who are
aware of and rightly fear the vampires
that lurk in the dark all around us it
goes into great detail about the biology
of the common vampire also known as
vampire draculae and believed to be the
progenitor to all other vampire species
as well as their diet behavior and the
best methods of hunting them the
following is a brief extract vampray
draculae is largely similar in shape and
form to homo sapien sapiens an erect
biped with a wingspan roughly equivalent
to its height the most obvious feature
discerning them from a human is the
shape of their hands the vampire's hands
are claw-like with long hard nails
extending up to two centimeters often
sharpened to a point the muscles in
these hands are taut and powerful they
can be quickly contracted to exert
immense pressure on anything in the
vampire's grasp this ability is commonly
used to crush the skulls or bones of
prey naturally the vampire's teeth are
the second source of notability the
fangs of a vampire are stuff of legend
and it is difficult to extricate myth
from fact dissection of the adult
specimens have noted sexual dimorphism
in the dental region while males have
two score and eight teeth two the
females to score they are less dangerous
four of the males can be described as
fangs both front facing two on the top
and two on the bottom each a centimeter
above the gum line comparatively females
have eight fangs four on the front and
two on each side her front fangs are up
to one and a half centimeter above the
gum line the legends have preserved one
important bit of truth regarding the
fangs they are used almost exclusively
to suck blood from the vampire's prey
they bite into the flesh most often of
the neck or thigh and the vampire uses
its lips to create a seal around the
incisions before sucking however study
of their feeding habits has led me to an
intriguing discovery as soon as the bee
separates itself from its prey its
saliva soothes the wound and encourages
faster clotting while this is pure
speculation your author theorizes that
this is an adaptation to preserve the
life of the prey in order to remain a
consistent food source a truly
fascinating piece of technical
literature next of course there is the
short but haunting piece titled leavings
of another world written by the great
thinker jack manganese this tone carries
an important lesson to all who wander
through the hallowed halls of the
wanderers library about the power of
words but it's not the kind of power you
might think allow this extract to expand
on that words have power indeed they
have the power to create but mostly they
have the power to destroy
does that really surprise you let me
demonstrate please think of an animal
any animal it could be anything right
two like it four-legged wings anything
but now suppose i said think of a
quadruped it can no longer be two-legged
can it it can no longer be a bird or a
fish and if i said think of a black
domesticated feline your choices are
narrower still
and finally think of bastard my pet
black cat at that point you have no
choices at all you may believe that each
step gives you more information but what
it really does is limit your imagination
and destroy possibilities the power to
destroy you see is much greater than the
power to create you didn't notice
because you yourself are a creature of
thoughts
ideas
language and ultimately
of words suppose i told you there was
once a world without language without
ideas without words of course world
itself is a word so it wasn't really a
world but we have to call it something
now don't we in this world there were no
limitations
everything that could be
was everything that couldn't be also was
it was a vast place of infinite
complexity but also of infinite
simplicity since everything that was or
wasn't also was or wasn't everything
else the endless variety was in fact all
the same you say it's difficult to
describe indeed that's the point it
can't be described it was everything and
anything and something and nothing and
all at once and not at all what happened
to it words of course it started with a
single simple word in a language that no
one speaks anymore no one knows where it
came from or how it sounded but i'll
tell you what it meant it meant red and
as soon as there was red there was also
not red the world had been neatly cloven
into red any every somethings and not
read any every some things it was the
first division and the very idea of
division spawned more ideas and more
words one two separate together us
them and from these came more
many
many more the piece then goes on to
reveal that the proliferation of
language destroyed this world further
until all that was left was the wreckage
our world how a universe of infinite
possibilities is slowly dulled by the
ever-expanding power of nomenclature
truly a disturbing thought for the more
metaphysical among you let's take
another book from king shash's
collection next comes a frightening
parable about hubris from the bard known
as jack of trades like many at classic
parable this piece tells the tale of an
intelligent spider a jack of trades as
the story puts it whose arrogance forges
him into the architect of his own demise
let's take a look at an extract shall we
i once meant a spider named jack a
sizeable fellow he was the size of my
fist and eight legs as long as my hand
they were dexterous too complimenting
his keen mind that was where his name
came from jack of trades for with each
leg he would conduct each of his trades
with one he was a blacksmith forging
steel like silk that with another he
would spin into death traps with a third
he would contemplate the design of his
web for he was an architect with the
fourth he would climb the tallest of
trees and basque in the daylight so that
all would see his splendor and in it
take delight oh yes he was proud why
wouldn't he be he was the most talented
spider to have ever graced the land his
craft as numerous as they were grand i
don't just weave webs he said to me i
weave works of art my traps instruments
of death so much finer than all the rest
then one day
jack hatched a plan
up the tallest of trees he climbed he
did not rest for two nights and two days
until he reached the highest branch the
word some proclaims say he could touch
the moon up there but i digress for one
thing was certain the height he had
reached was a thing to impress what jack
did next was more august still working
each of his renowned legs he weaved a
web from the base of the branch to its
end so mighty in scale was it that he
said it would catch him the sun and make
him master of all that it touched it
will bring me the moon too he told me
once and with the light of the brightest
star i shall be master of the night
catch them he did for as the sun climbed
it found itself twined in the mesh of
jack's web as for the moon it soon found
itself strewn with jack string which
clung to its opalescent veneer as it
drew near to its ever evasive lover the
bringer of day now they were tied to one
another in jack's trap for him to reign
over it was thus he crafted himself a
throne of sunlight and moonlight the
very heavens made to bow before his
majesty yet it was not to last the rest
of the tale details the downfall of jack
the spider as he devours the sun and
moon above driven by his boundless
hunger for greatness soon enough he was
left with nothing to consume and in his
despair tumbled from his web down to his
doom so is oft in the way with those
pushed by unchecked ambition time to
blow the dust off of another one of the
library's forbidden texts this one
entitled a restless wanderer on the
earth is a particularly interesting
piece for anyone fascinated by the
enigmatic life of scp-073
also known as kane this piece features a
person named bluebird buying a jar
containing kane's memories from a
merchant possibly affiliated with
marshall carter and dark limited it is a
complex tale concerning many small
fragments from kane's life thousands of
years in the past here is a brief
excerpt the man found kane ben adam in
the endless wilderness of the between
places the man was beautiful to look
upon with bronze skin and shaggy black
hair his clothing was cut of animal skin
of fashions pleasing to the eye but cain
was not pleased to see him the man knew
his name i am a priest the man said a
year ago you passed through my village i
wish to follow you then but i was held
back by the others then the crop failed
and a plague swept through our village
only i was able to save myself and then
there were none to hold me back i have
searched for you since and now i have
finally found you cain frowned he tried
to wander only those lands where the
soil was wild and suffused with power
enough to resist his curse or else lands
where the inhabitants knew how to
refresh the land which his curse had
made baron when he needed to pass
through civilization he avoided the
fields he had long ago discovered that
his curse had a limit 48 cubits around
him or a length similar to 12 times his
own height enough to judge with the
naked eye but that did not account for
the times he was not fully aware often
taken with wanderlust sometimes not even
fully awake he would walk in a trance
according to where his feet took him
alone after these periods he could awake
having destroyed the entire harvest for
a village i am truly sorry
cain said the man looked astonished you
are cain the wanderer father of the lost
children and the great beasts you are
the god of death the other gods the
lesser gods would not save my village
i worship them once i despise them now i
come now to worship you they were your
family kane said even if they were not i
cannot be pleased about bringing more
death to those who did not deserve it
you are testing me my lord the man's
teeth cleaned i promise you i will not
disappoint you i will become your
follower and your priest foolish cain
said and continued walking the man
followed him it is clear that the curse
cain is forced to carry since committing
the terrible sin of murder against his
own brother weighs heavily upon him and
the powers he possesses now are both a
blessing and a terrible detriment to the
normal life he would have led as with
anything involving cain it is a deeply
tragic tale next comes another insight
into a normally secretive world a piece
entitled the exhibition written by an
aspiring an artist named artifacts the
piece details his frustrating experience
hosting his artwork at a private
exhibition hosted by the sinister
members of marshall carter and dark
limited and of course here is a brief
extract i had never been so
disappointed
before tonight was supposed to be my big
night the an art exhibition that would
have defined my career hosted by the
richest men of the anomalous world
marshall carter and dark luminaries from
all across the multiverse had come to
see our work i remember how surprised
and excited i was to see the letter that
i had even been accepted into the
exhibition to receive one of these had
been my dream since i was a child
learning about all the wonders of the
anomalous on my father's knee how the
letter looked so formal with the logo of
m c and d printed at the bottom that i
thought it sealed my future forever i
spent five hours fretting beforehand i
eventually settled on a suit to wear a
black and white chessboard pattern only
with actual chess pieces that moved and
played games over the fabric i had
specifically requested that it be made
with some of the most famous games of
history sewn into it when i looked down
at myself i could not tell which game
was which before i could second guess my
choice of clothing i looked at the time
and realized that i was running slightly
late and left in a hurry rushing to the
portal that the letter told me to go in
between a bookshop and a bowling alley
when i arrived my astonishment at seeing
the place was a feeling i would never
forget it was ridiculously surreal like
if m c escher painted an art museum and
the museum was filled with escher's
paintings with the paintings themselves
being alive oh the chandeliers were made
from glowing crystals almost looking
more like disco balls than chandeliers
the crowd there was as impressive as the
art with all sorts of people from all
sorts of dimensions dressed in finest
suits capes and cloaks that money could
buy as i approached the host a tall
imposing figure with grey robes a metal
mask and a mane of white hair i felt
very intimidated yes yes
i've been awaiting your arrival natura
he was saying to a woman before him a
human with a green dress that i quickly
noticed was actually made out of leaves
and dark green hair to match flowing
down past her shoulders with flowers in
her hair and clothes your work is
waiting for you in the west wing the
woman who i assumed was named natura
eagerly nodded and looked over to her
right she started walking so quickly she
almost bumped into me the night didn't
go much better for artifice after that
xanar pieces were a painting of a woman
who makes you fall in love a vase that
kills anything put inside of it and a
little statue of an archer who fires
real arrows the representatives of
marshall carter and dark were not
impressed by this meagre display leaving
artifacts who'd mainly gotten in from
his father's business connections
feeling well let's say
less than stoked but the wanderers
library isn't all just technical
documents and pros there's also a fair
share of spellbinding poetry in these
dusty old pages take for example stars
wait for no man by the illustrious poet
who goes only by dr pan it is a powerful
and melancholy peace presented here in
falls the abyss is an infinitude unknown
and
unknowable
creatures with mouths over throats seek
insight into their existence gazing at
that which only gazes back they choke as
they look windpipe spent awkwardly tears
trickling from their eyes windows
reflecting a goal
unachievable eyes peer into darkness
searching for more and more
yearning hoping desiring but not doing
never going
weeping at the beauty beyond reach
a number tried reaching out to the void
but the other scoffed drowning the door
with tears all while they rested their
asses in the dirt an eternity separates
that which seeks and that which is
sought eternity only grows as they gaze
on
dreaming but not doing
stars wait for no man
the wanderers library is a truly
fascinating place with so much strange
beauty and arcane knowledge to gather up
and learn would you like us to cover
more of the many esoteric volumes in the
library's infinite shelves let us know
down in the comments and we thoroughly
recommend you check out all the full
tales in the library itself using the
link in the description
just be careful when you do so it is so
very easy to get lost in there now go
check out scp-6000 the serpent the moose
and the wanderers library and scp
serpent's hand explained for more on the
legendary library between dimensions